[Music]
let's face it
the internet is stressful clickbait
articles
angry comment sections addictive social
media and rampant misuse of personal
data
did you ever wish that there was someone
looking out for you on the internet
someone watching over you protecting you
from all the horrors that lurk on the
digital space
well believe it or not the catholic
church has a patron saint of the
internet
introducing saint isidore of seville now
don't let the fact that he was born in
the year 560 bother you
yes he may have never used the internet
but this venerated monk is supposed to
be god's heavenly advocate of the
information age
in this video let's take a further look
at the life of this tech savvy saint
and how he ended up becoming the patron
saint of the internet
we'll also discover what you can do to
become a saint yourself
results of course may vary in
christianity
saints are venerated individuals
believed to be exceptionally holy
they might have lived a life of extreme
piety such as the generous saint
nicholas
who gave much of his earthly belongings
to charity and
also is the basis for santa claus today
some may have performed incredible
miracles
like st patrick who reportedly drove all
the snakes out of ireland
a deed so magnificent that every year
people dress up in green and go out
binge drinking many of these saints are
made special representatives of
something
this is known as being a patron saint
for example
saint nicholas is the patron saint of
children merchants and brewers
a great christmas mix if you ask me and
sin patrick is famously the patron saint
of ireland
but there are some really obscure and
unusual patron saints
take for example sent joseph of
cupertino he represents
school tests and examinations and is
often depicted as flying about the place
apparently that's something he could do
which is nice there's also
saint vitus paid trans saint of
oversleeping said antonia padua
patron saint of lost property saint
sebastian patron saint of pandemics
and saint barbara patron saint of get
this
russian missile strategic forces
basically if you can think of something
there's probably a patron saint for it
one of my favorites has got to be
saint drogo who is no lie the patron
saint of ugly people and coffee
so if you have self-esteem issues and a
caffeine addiction
the catholic church has a saint for that
now patron saints are a hallmark of the
catholic church
but for some christian denominations
particularly protestant churches
they're highly controversial and many
are rejected outright
there are some protestant churches that
view patron saints
as another form of idol worship they'd
often hold up the commandment
thou shalt not make unto thee any graven
image found in the bible
as reason why this practice should be
banned others would suggest that the
very idea of a patron saint
is inherited from pagan religions for
example the greek goddess
athena was the patroness of wisdom and
war as well as the guardian deity of the
city of athens
for whom the polis is actually named
after there was a thriving tradition of
praying to the goddess and in return
you would receive divine protection
against any invaders
therefore they would argue that a patron
saint is a hang-up from greco-roman
religion
after all why not just pray to god or
jesus directly
however a catholic might respond that
this whole patron saint thing has been
massively misunderstood
instead of praying to a saint to fix
your problems the saint is really there
to represent you in front of god
the theological term for this is called
intercession you kind of pray with the
saints
and they pray for you so double the
prayers double the chance things will
work out
or not anyway the whole for and against
patron saints
is another topic and a controversial one
at that literal wars have been fought
over this kind
of thing so whether you believe in
patron saints or not
let's turn to saint isador who currently
has the marvelous title of patron saint
of the internet
so for someone who is the heavenly
advocate of the internet
sin isidor never even touched a computer
born in the year 560
he would predate the launch of the
internet by 1429 years
bear in mind that he was 610 years off
the invention of the wheelbarrow which
was first recorded in europe
in 1170. the reason why saint isidore
got connected to the internet is his
ambitious quest to compile
all the world's knowledge into a single
book known as the etymology
it is a 20 book compendium with
everything from metallurgy
medicine to mathematics it's during this
work where he also invented the full
stop
comma and colon so if you ever get
caught up by tricky punctuation
it's this person to blame with the dawn
of the internet in the early 90s
humanity entered an unprecedented age
where information could be accessed
instantly
this is especially true with the launch
of wikipedia on the 15th of january 2001
which currently has 6 million articles
in english the site is an online
database
which possesses all of human knowledge
gained thus far
so too was saint isidore's etymology
because of this association
the saint quickly became viewed as the
patron of the internet
his enthusiasm for knowledge was
allegedly noticed by pope john paul ii
who reportedly declared him to be a
saint of all things digital
in fact using the internet i found this
prayer for saint isidore
it's a prayer asking for protection from
the internet
grant we beseech thee that through the
intercession of saint isidore
bishop and doctor during our journeys
through the internet
we will direct our hands and eyes only
to that which is pleasing to thee
and treat with charity and patience all
those souls whom we
encounter i don't know about you but
this saint seems to be the catholic
church's alternative
to anti-virus software there is only one
problem
whether pope john paul ii officially
made sin isidor the patron saint of the
internet
is actually unknown there's actually no
vatican document that officially says
he is the internet's advocate and so in
fact
his status may be unofficial in recent
years
there's another candidate seen to become
the official patron saint of the
internet
as well as the first millennial saint
his name is carlo acutis
carla was born in 1991 to an italian
family living in london
whilst his parents were not very
religious carla became more and more
devoted to the catholic church
allegedly even asking to receive his
first communion
at the young age of seven to the
surprise of his parents
he became an avid churchgoer and as a
teenager
he became deeply involved in charity
work and even spent his allowance to
feed the homeless and buy them sleeping
bags
when not thinking about matters of faith
or helping the unfortunate
in his downtime young carlo enjoyed
coding and computer programming
he became keenly fascinated in the
burgeoning internet
and made a website cataloging all the
eucharistic miracles
however it takes a really sad turn this
young man's life
would be tragically cut short after a
sudden an unexpected illness
carlo received a terminal diagnosis of
leukemia
it did not take long for his health to
quickly deteriorate and on october 2006
carlos sadly passed he was just 15.
even after his death however carlo's
story didn't end there
in 2013 some seven years after he died
he entered the path
of sainthood in order for someone to
become a saint in the eyes of the
catholic church
they need to pass a few steps it varies
a little bit but it typically involves
having two miracles performed in your
name
so here is how carlo is on the way to
becoming canonized
that's another word for becoming a saint
if you fancy yourself a saint
well listen up here's a quick
step-by-step guide
step one become a servant of god
the bad news is is that in order to
become a saint you have to have already
died
no one can become a saint in their
lifetime the good news is
is that there are things you can do to
ensure you get a sainthood and it's
basically
be a good person before you die the
first stage on the road to sainthood is
becoming a so-called
servant of god in short roughly five
years after you die
an investigation will open up to see
whether you are sufficiently holy during
your
life whether you displayed good acts of
character and helped the less fortunate
if the church approves this first stage
well then you receive the title
servant of god based on the good life
carlo lived
including all his service to the church
and in building his website
he was approved and given the title
servant of god
in 2013. stage 2 demonstrate
heroic virtue soon after carlo was named
a servant of god
a campaign sprung up and a petition
quickly got underway
to make him a saint the next step
however is that you need to prove that
you displayed
heroic virtue in your life where servant
of god is where you lived a good life
heroic virtue is where you lived a great
life
it has to be proven that you went above
and beyond in your virtuous deeds
at this point it is the pope himself who
gets to decide whether you exceptionally
well behaved
in 2018 pope francis approved that carlo
indeed demonstrated
heroic virtue in his life and he was
thus elevated to the status of
venerable stage 3 beatification
now we get onto supernatural territory
if you want to progress to become a
saint
you need to start making miracles happen
in your name two is the magic number
beatification is when you get your first
miracle
news was coming out of brazil that a
little boy had been miraculously healed
when his mother prayed to carlo to
intercede from heaven on her behalf
another detailed investigation was
quickly sprung up and in late 2020 the
vatican soon confirmed that carlos had
been beatified
so now he has the title blessed carlo
cutis stage four sainthood
the fourth and final stage in order to
reach this level and become canonized
there has to be a second miracle
performed in your name
and of course it's got to be verified by
the catholic church
and the pope himself now currently carlo
is still batified
he is one step away from becoming a
saint so
if there is news about any more miracles
attributed to carlo
he may indeed be canonized this is yet
to happen
if it does carlo acutis will likely
replace saint isidore
as the official patron saint of the
internet although i'm non-religious
myself
to my mind it would make more sense to
have carlo and knots and israel as the
patron saint of the internet
for all his achievements in compiling
the world's knowledge sin isidor
never really used the internet himself
nor would he have fathomed that the
world's information
could be accessed in a pocket centuries
later it always baffles me the profound
effect
the internet continues to have in our
lives we use it for work
school to talk to our families and
entertainment right now
you're watching a video through the
internet about whatever strange topics i
like to cover
so for now we'll have to see who the
real patron saint of the internet is
for all of its faults the internet is
pretty amazing
yes it can be stressful but nothing a
patron saint can't fix
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this video as much as i
enjoyed making it if you like this kind
of content and want to see more
why not subscribe i like it a comment
also go a really long way
as of this video's upload the channel
recently passed 300 000 subscribers
thank you all so much it's been an
absurd journey so far but i'm really
glad you're on the way with me
oh also feel free to join our channel's
discord surfer
it's a community-led group where
like-minded folk discuss all kinds of
interesting topics
and it's great to see so many of you
people on there either way
i look forward to seeing you next time
bye